HIM.
REPORTING IN MISSION, TEXAS,
BILL MELUGIN, FOX NEWS.
>> Shannon: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS CLOSING A
TRUMP ERA OFFICE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
SET UP TO ASSIST AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHO WERE VICTIMS OF
CRIMES ALLEGEDLY COMMITTED BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
BUT SPRING INFORMER ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL MATT WHITAKER
FOR MORE.
THIS IS THE HEADLINE FROM THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS, U.S. CLOSES
TRUMPCARE OFFICE FOR VICTIMS OF
IMMIGRANT CRIME.
HAS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SAYS IT HAS DISMANTLED A
TRUMPCARE A GOVERNMENT OFFICE
CREATED TO HELP VICTIMS OF
CRIMES COMMITTED BY IMMIGRANTS.
THEY SAY IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A OFFICE
EXPANDED TO HELP ALL KINDS OF
PEOPLE WHETHER THEY ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY OR NOT.
THAT PARTICULAR OFFICE WAS TO
HELP AMERICANS HURT BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
WHEN YOU MAKE OF THE CHANGE?
>> IT'S A REAL PROBLEM.
I SEE VICTIMS OF CRIMES ALWAYS
NEEDING MORE RESOURCES NOT LESS,
IT'S GOING TO SPREAD WHAT
LIMITED RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE
TO THOSE VICTIMS OF CRIMES TO
OTHERS THAT MAY BE ARE NOT AS
WORTHY OR NOT AS DESERVING,
ESPECIALLY IF WE ARE GIVING
LAWYERS TO IMMIGRANTS AND
HELPING OTHERS THAT ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
I THINK CLOSING THIS OFFICE
SENDS A REALLY BAD SIGNAL TO
VICTIMS OF CRIMES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION JUST DOESN'T CARE
AS MUCH AS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DID.
>> Shannon: LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE BORDER.
THE SITUATION IS ONLY GROWN
WORSE.
ONE OF THE ISSUES I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT HIS DRUG TRAFFICKING.
ROLL CALL HAD AN OPINION PIECE
BY SENATOR PORTMAN SAYING THE
BIDENS BORDER POLICIES ARE
WORSENING THE OPEN YARD CRISIS.
MOVING MORE FENTANYL INTO THE
U.S.
IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS BORDER
PATROL HAS SEIZED 5400 POUNDS OF
FENTANYL, ENOUGH TO KILL
1.2 BILLION PEOPLE OR THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF THE U.S. MORE THAN
THREE TIMES.
THESE LAWMAKERS SAY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S RADICAL POLICY
CHANGES HAVE ENCOURAGED DRUG
CARTELS TO SMUGGLE MORE UNLAWFUL
IMMIGRANTS AND LETHAL ILLICIT
SUBSTANCES ACROSS THE BORDER.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
SITUATION AND THE RISE AND
THINGS LIKE FENTANYL?
IN 2019 U.S. SOURCES SAY 37,000
AMERICANS DIED BY A FENTANYL
OVERDOSE AND THEY PREDICT THE
NUMBERS ARE ONLY GOING TO BE
WORSE.
>> YEAH, FENTANYL IS A NASTY
DRUG THAT IS REALLY A SCOURGE IN
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS THE MORE
ACTIVITY IN THE MORE ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS WE HAVE ON OUR BORDER,
THAT ALLOWS THE CARTELS TO
POTENTIALLY SEND MORE DRUGS AND
MORE ILLEGAL ITEMS ACROSS THE
BORDER BECAUSE THERE'S MORE
PEOPLE TO CARRY THEM AND THERE'S
MORE ACTIVITY.
THE FENTANYL IS OBVIOUSLY,
SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS GENERALLY ARE
KILLING AMERICANS.
IT'S ONLY GETTING WORSE THE MORE
THAT'S HERE IN THE COUNTRY AND
BEING USED.
GETTING CONTROL OF THE BORDER IS
THE FIRST STEP IN TRYING TO
ARREST THIS PROBLEM OF ILLEGAL
FENTANYL IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
>> Shannon: I WANT TO GET A
COMMENT, FBI DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY SAYS THERE IS
CARTEL ACTIVITY SPILLING OVER
INTO THE U.S.
PARTIALLY HE SAID, HE WAS
ANSWERING A QUESTION ABOUT
PEOPLE GETTING HERE AND BEING
INDENTURED SERVANTS.
TO PAY BACK THE CARTEL FOR
GETTING THEM TO THE U.S.
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER, CARTEL
CONTROLLING.
>> CHRIS IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE CARTELS ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF A LAX ENFORCEMENT STRUCTURE
OF THE BORDER AND WE ARE SEEING
EVER-INCREASING LEGAL ACTIVITY
AND IT IS SPILLING.
WHETHER IT'S SAFE HOUSES,
ILLEGAL CAR CHASES THAT ARE
INJURING AND SOMETIMES KILLING
PEOPLE.
ALL THE OTHER ACTIVITY WE ARE
SEEING AROUND THE BORDER THAT'S
BRINGING IT INTO THE
UNITED STATES AND MOVING THE
BORDER NORTH IN A VERY
CONCERNING WAY.
>> Shannon: MATT WHITAKER,
ALWAYS GREAT TO HAVE Y